[Music]
I can't remember it
that's how it sounds in my head guys we
got ourselves a trailer for The Penguin
series the eight episode run meant to
tie in the you know from the Batman I
got about seven in the morning guys
we're covering Laura and this is not
going to be a cohesive discussion today
but I'm G fueled up so I'm ready to
anticipate everything coming our way
leave a like that would mean the world
today
and
now we watch the trailer that's how this
works
[Music]
this
this is one of those moments
but please let there be actual new
footage you gotta ask yourself
what kind of Life do I want
you know
the world ain't built for guys like us
that's why we gotta take whatever we
decide
is ours
was caught my phone calls right in
trying to push me out
[Music]
you're seeing what I could do
awesome if you step out of line even
once I got you like a goddamn fish
people are saying my name on the streets
after you're gone never mean something
laughs
[Laughter]
oh hell yeah and I got them
he's got so much shine on his teeth
oh that's cool they kept it as the
Batman text I hate that
I look why did you change it
to Max oh yeah hi
why it's why would you at least put like
Warner Brothers in there or something I
mean HBO is such a ubiquitous name and
it doesn't seem like a massive overhaul
just let it be HBO
I hear Max I'm more likely to think of
Cinemax Yes actually sure Max original
or Maximilian from goofy
come on take it to the max come on
HBO could that be instead Max original
uh this looks really cool this looks
like The Sopranos I love The Sopranos I
love the Batman movies not three times
in the cinemas I'm excited to see what
Colin Farrell can do here this just
feels completely original and such an
original take for it like I think
penguin is such a compelling character
in The live-action mediums you know
someone asked in a live stream of ours
not long ago who was our like your
favorite Batman's Rogue gallery now I
never really find penguin to be one of
my favorites specifically when it comes
to like the comic books but in live
action runs he I feel like they didn't
do such a great job of variety with him
what we got in like Batman Returns well
we got in the Gotham show to now what we
got in the Batman to see what Colin
Farrell was able to do and the kind of
talent he has just evolved into he was
always been talented but now it's just
something else now right I absolutely am
in love with just the little tidbits
that we got here because this looks
gritty compelling a real opportunity to
see this guy rise to power after being
like second fiddle to Falcone and the
Batman film it's such a unique kind of
character to look at and focus on for
your main character on a TV show you
know he brings such a gravitas to it and
I love how this looks like the Batman
this feels like a film it doesn't feel
like a television show this feels like
an actual film yeah exactly I I think
they've done a very sort of interesting
thing in grounding all of this the way
that they have because it does lend
itself in a in a holy other way to what
we're used to to interconnectivity like
this like it's really easy to kind of
set things on the ground and then build
this sort of yeah gritty World out from
it and I think too there is something
about the penguin in live action in
particular that I think plays on like I
think you can read oftentimes like oh
yeah you know like hi like upper crusty
kind of uh uh uh Mafia corporate
criminal kind of type but then you know
you you apply that to live action and
there are so many other kind of
touchstones and references to that
particular aesthetic and Cinema that you
can make I think a particularly
compelling Twist on that with a comic
book character that yeah takes you uh
slightly Beyond what's familiar in those
terms and so yeah I'm excited to see how
this Blends a Sopranos or you know just
a a very Mafia type thing a very
grounded type thing with the elements of
height that Matt Reeves Batman world
does include because while it's not
obviously the most height in Batman
there are aspects of it that lend
themselves to that and I'm curious to
see in what ways the show does go a
little bit Bonkers because you know as
grounded as the Batman is there is those
there are those moments that are big and
iconic and and feel like you know scopic
action so uh yeah and Colin Farrell man
he's just like I I don't know he just
seems like he's fully given himself over
to this character and has fully
disappeared into it well and I'm also
interested in the setting that this is
going to be taking place soon because as
we're looking at this footage you know
when we ended off in the Batman was the
uh The Ground Zero uh flooding situation
but it looks like a lot of it has you
know been repaired because you have a
lot of these shots in the streets and
stuff where people are walking about
people are dining in restaurants and so
it doesn't I don't know what the time
Jump is from the Batman to this series
but I'm curious to see what the
evolution of the Gotham world has
devolved into and how the little toy
with the conversations about Batman
specifically and what Batman is doing
while this whole Adventure that we're
focusing on with penguin is is going
down and unlike The Sopranos where it
starts off with Tony Soprano who is you
know
already on top he's he's already the
head of the family right this is a guy
who you're going to watch Rise through
the ranks you know you have situations
write it in this trailer too where you
can see that he's being a territory he's
got guys holding him down like he's
really still having to prove himself and
try to gain some type of power right and
I I can't wait to see how they get you
to like
like the anti-hero angle like the
challenge the audience into rooting for
this guy who you don't root for in the
Batman movie you know you don't you
don't root for this fella no but you can
but this time you're gonna I don't know
if it'll root for him but you're gonna
have to be investing going on his
journey at least I can see how they
could pitch him as an underdog yeah well
he is especially for penguin like yeah
he has to rise to the Rings he's
obviously he doesn't have superpowers or
anything like that you know yeah yeah
yeah and in this world I mean just him
being like disfigured and having this
limp and everything there's something I
think that you can use a lot of that to
to create sympathy within the audience
and create nuances where you're like
yeah even if this is a bad guy I get why
but they should tie it into kind of what
they did at Batman Returns you gotta you
know get him an army of penguins by the
end as that should be the actual villain
they are hiding for the Batman 2 is
penguin in the army of penguins yeah
it's not penguin until he bites off
somebody's nose too yeah nothing
Penguins
where do we get so many arctic Birds
climate change
people are on my ass about protecting
the wildlife
what do you want from me that's why I'm
being called the fascist
that's right as I take on a rich
billionaire who owns clubs and
stuff around Gotham but I am the best
all right guys well what did you think
about this teaser leave your thoughts
down below
subscribe leave a like and I want to do
it
Adelia Chamberlain Adelia we're shouting
you out because you remind us most of
the personality traits of a penguin sure
because you know it's a constant journey
of doing your best to to live in the
present despite whatever thought
processes can go off in your head you
have a clear vision of how you want
things to be of how things should be
right these are this is just penguin
facts you know what I'm saying you also
take your commitment seriously example a
you've never left the patreon you've
committed since day one it's amazing
being around you you're enthusiastic
you're upbeat and friendly like all
penguins you know what I mean uh all my
friends are penguins yeah you're not I
mean
Dependable you can be counted on and
that's such an important trait to have
in life uh I mean I don't know if you're
personally threat of my conflict or
criticism but I feel like handle it you
know when it comes down to it like a
penguin sure like a real penguin you're
more of a penguin than Penguins that's
true that's true and you're good in cold
weather situations you can you can Brave
the stereotypes they can handle it
you're good in any type of climate
whether it be in a Gotham City type
Metropolis or a an Arctic type of tundra
yeah you know you know it's true the
penguins are in every zoo and every
favorite word I am a xenophobic a
closed-minded jerk but you're not Adelia
and that's what's important you inspire
me to be a better guy thanks for
penguining our lives
[Music]